all those
years living the life of
someone I didn't even
know let me tell you about you I want to
make you rich you see the bomb
trees they tell you anything's possible
no one cares about reality
anymore different these days it's going
on with
you I can't remember a man I wanted to
be just don't threaten me with leaving
okay just do what you want to
do you don't want love you want a love
experience they are like flavors
sometimes you want raspberries after
going to while it won some
strawberry you have love in you I know
it
blind suppose it isn't there for
me I was afraid when I was
young afraid of
Life un pays for
[Music]
it
once the soul was perfect and had wings
and could soar into
heaven you gave me
peace
Joy
love find your
way from
Darkness to
light
[Music]
remember